[Music]
hello and welcome to martial matters
with me winston marshall at the
spectator in this series i've been
exploring freedom of expression in the
creative industries amongst other things
and today i'm joined by actor turned
politician and now again
actor
lawrence fox lawrence welcome hi wen how
are you doing i'm good thank you well
can i start by saying congratulations
after
a very tempestuous couple of years where
i think january 2020 you appeared on bbc
question time it's very easy to try to
turn to racism at everybody and it's
really starting what worries me about
your comment is you are a white
privileged male who has
can i can't help what i am i was born
like this it's an immutable
characteristic so to call me a white
privileged male is to be racist
and shortly after for the opinions you
expressed there which seems to be on the
whole britain isn't racist yeah you uh
lost your agent you
uh
we're in a battle with equity the actors
union
and it's sort of your your
two decade long acting career seem to
unravel quite quickly but you're back
and um
on off sabbatical yeah
um and you have just uh
launched put out released my son hunter
a short biopic
about
joe biden present of the united states
son hunter biden his relationship with
his son i love my dad and i just want to
make him proud
so
tell us about hunter biden oh dear old
hunter um
yeah i'm not sure i'm back by the way i
think it's more a sabbatical from
cancellation which is um
which i well i hope it isn't but i think
it probably is um hunter biden uh he's a
very troubled guy isn't he i am a royal
fuck-up
aren't we
all you have no idea
no one can [ __ ] up the way that i [ __ ]
up
he seems to as far as the laptops are
concerned have
pretty much helped sell america to the
chinese as far as i can gather what
about the other companies you made deals
with
they were all tied to the communist
party we look forward to working with
you and hope to hear much about your
father and his interests
will do comrades
it's difficult now because i've got two
perceptions of him one as a professional
you know as an artist you just go i've
just got to represent this the humanity
of this person and not judge them
otherwise you just look naf i hate
actors that do play political roles
politically
um and then i've got my private
perception of him which is you know less
charitable i suppose but the acting of
him was more charitable the film does a
good
job of showing
the
the
hard ship he's had you know his mother
and sister killed in a car crash early
and then his uh brother beau
dying of a brain
tumor looks so innocent
[Music]
found me first
you do a good job i think of showing
that side of him as well as the more
difficult morally questionable aspects
of him so i think in terms of a piece of
what you do thumbs up thumbs up thumbs
up but let's talk about the the chinese
corruption you say that he has sold out
uh america to
china what exactly has he done
well you know this is all of the deals
that were done which are chronicled in
the film
from the face recognition technology
companies all of this stuff that he did
on behalf of of
for china on and you know in the name of
in the name of his dad in these names of
these deals and he got um there is you
know chronicled this 10 for the big guy
enumeration will need to be split six
ways
i'll hold ten percent for the big guy
[Music]
big guy big guy is well i think who else
would the big guy be
so you've got bad you've got joe and
then his brother i can't remember his
brother's name but um you sort of wipe
it don't you actually once you've done
something you've just i've completely
wiped that script from my brain and all
of the things about what's right okay
but you know you sort of
it's
clearly chronicled in the laptop from
hell and in
in the film you know yeah
laptop hell is the it's the divine book
yeah and then it so it what's
astonishing is that people
still
think that it's contested whether the
laptop is authentic or not well let's go
into the history for people who might
not know in april 2019 a laptop turned
up in hunter biden's home state of
delaware in a repair shop
later that year it was confiscated by
the fbi how the [ __ ] did your laptop end
up at the fbi
i thought they'd refuse to accept it
it's all worked out for now but if this
blows up
they may change their minds not much
more was heard of it but a copy of the
laptop or the hard drive was sent
to rudy giuliani's
lawyer
and that was september 2020
and
the new york post
public reported on the story uh october
2020 so just before the presidential
elections
and that story was completely
and utterly silenced by social media
twitter took down the story only last
month mark zuckerberg
admitted on the joe rogan podcast that
uh he um was told today he was taught to
by the by the fbi and so for the first
week for the story he he boosted it is
there regret for
not
having it evenly distributed yeah i mean
it's it sucks yeah yeah i mean because i
mean it turned out after the fact i mean
the fact trackers looked into it no one
was able to say it was false he admitted
long before that they'd done that though
in a congressional committee hearing
zuckerberg he admitted that he
what he told joe rogan wasn't news
that was he said that
very soon after
um but that is terrifying isn't it just
the idea that um
and i think they did some polling on the
or sort of sane democrats rather than
the sort of squad democrats to find out
what whether it might or might not have
affected their vote
and they were saying it did so yeah i
saw one part saying 4.8 percent of
democrats would have voted the other way
which could have been enough to change
the result of the election so it's
pretty terrifying isn't it that
big tech have this power
and you know bearing in mind that there
was four years from 2016 of
the democrats saying that trump had only
got in on russian collusion and they he
basically spent four years investigating
him and impeachment doing all those sort
of things whatever your views are on
trump
it was pretty underhanded play
so then to find out that big tech then
censored this
and
you know
like twitter stopped showing new york
the new york post story and zuckerberg
de-boosting it that is essentially
i mean not sure what the word you could
use for it other than election rigging
in a way because you're affecting the
result you're potentially affecting the
result of an election and that is
therefore rigging it
well i mean
certainly free speech seems to be
in dire state in in america and and here
as well
so for you making the film was there a a
motivation
to get this story out is it is this a an
issue that
really is important to you
oh not really you know for me i just
it's i'm it's boring i'm an i'm an
artist you know that's what i am i've
been sucked into another realm which is
unusual and unfamiliar territory for me
that i want to be an artist so it was
the only script anyone's ever sent me in
the sort of two years not so much since
question time my agent hung on for a bit
but then once the um people started
calling me a racist and stuff like that
then my agent ditched me so it's the
only script i got so i just wanted to i
quite like playing troubled people so
that was fun but i and i'm i'm i am
interested in in american politics so
but i wasn't like yes i've got hunter
biden i must play him it was more this
is a fascinating story and i also want
to work again as an actor in front of a
camera because i missed it i mean what
it seems so
ludicrous that that the state of
filmmaking
is that if you have your opinions
you can lose as much as you've lost do
you think it's
justified you think it's fair enough
should actors stay out of politics or
you know is it have you been treated
unfairly whereas some actors can happily
announce their support of various
political leaders but if you support the
wrong
quote wrong political leaders you lose
it all well i mean some actors can punch
comedians in the face and get a standing
ovation you know what i mean their
careers aren't over
um i think it depends certainly there's
a there is a bias towards anything which
is
deemed as
i think sort of sort of very small sees
social or even classical liberalism
which is i suppose where i am actually
at i've probably got a few more
right-wing views and some left-wing
views as well but i'm probably in the
middle the overton political overton
windows had to move so far in one
direction just to accommodate this new
very sensorious woke movement
that um
yeah i mean i i felt personally very
upset this week about that because it's
like i was trained to do this job
and you know you know as you say there's
millions of actors that turn around and
will come out in support of what can say
horrendous things actually some of the
things that i mean particularly some of
the things maxine peak i've seen her
who's that she's an actress
a you know
hugely left-wing actress
and some of the things she said and got
away with and is almost applauded for i
think is is damaging for free speech
because it means that you know who wants
to watch uh
sort of morally superior
moral lecture in show business or within
the arts so should we stay out of
politics i think it's bad it's bad both
ways because you don't want
you don't want woke right-winging which
is essentially what might under could be
if it hadn't been directed by such a
good director in robert darvey it could
have been sort of right we're going to
troll and stick two fingers up to all of
the
wokies and you don't want extreme left
wing thinking you want some you want a
conversation between the two that's what
i'm kind of keen on but yeah i certainly
felt that
i must have because i called it i said
it was a sort of
moment wasn't it that question time i
said what
from what i hear a lot of people say to
me you said what needed to be said at
the time it needed to be said i think i
i think what happened to me is not
massively dissimilar from what happened
to you is it it's the more
they expect you to have one view and you
maybe don't have that view yeah the
bigger your punishment needs to be in
order to put others off making the same
transgression did you have a feeling
going into that bbc question time
that
what
that you would lose your career for
expressing your opinion did you have a
sense before going into it that actually
you were self-censoring or that you
couldn't really express yourself within
the creative industries within film
it was fine
i
for
years i never hadn't expressed myself as you
well know you know i always say what i
think but it was fine and then there was
this sudden
and quite swift emergence of
you know this idea of oppression
diversity and inclusion i remember my
final acting job before this hunter film
was a white lines
netflix series and there was they
offered me the job in the room and it
then there was this long conversation
about um the fact that if they hired
they would they were deciding whether to
make me black or white and i was like
why don't you just
get the best person for the job
so the real hyper-racialized
consciousness came into the business and
then you know a lot of actors would
carry on behaving totally normally but
there would be a small coterie of the
permanently offended and oppressed
who would complain and i would get
irritated when
somebody's being paid 25 000 pounds a
week was talking about how you know
underrepresented they have been and how
you know they believe that
they are the victims of oppression in
some way and i'm not going if you're the
victims of
racial oppression and you know you're
doing pretty well out of it on 25 grand
a week at the end of the day and also
there was this consciousness right
long before films have always been
diverse i don't know you know i was
watching um backdraft the other day
because i like watching old kind of tub
thumping american movies i don't know
about glass it's a movie it's one of the
last movies made without cgi about fire
so it's about a fire fireman it's a
thriller it's a brilliant movie and it's
beautifully directed but it's very
diverse and you never notice but now
because of the hyper racialization of
everything you notice don't you
and that's something that makes me
really sad i hate seeing skin color do
you have a sense of whether in the
industry
it's uh popul these these
ideas that you're criticizing are
popularly held or is it a minority
within the industry or of gate keepers
who are controlling it uh controlling
the narrative in that sense what how
how on whole how would you describe the
the the film industry is is it um
is it a homogeneous in its thought or is
there a mixed a mixed group it's
definitely a mixed group i mean look the
further away you you must have had this
as well when you were when you were
playing the further away you are from
the camera the more
the views are more
sort of rounded and you know there's
more banter and the closer you get to
the camera and the sort of
intelligentsia the more
left-wing so it sort of starts off
right-wing as you walk on set to go past
the chippies and stuff like that and it
gets steadily more left-wing as you
arrive in front of a camera so i think i
think it is a it's a minority but it's a
well-supported and funded minority isn't
it diversification inclusion which
essentially is the exact opposite of
what it says
is
you know um now kind of
kneaded into all of these um
films showbiz all of it you know you've
got after you've got radha sent an email
around apologizing for being really
racist and it's just like
david harwood and adrian leicester came
out of radha fagben they came out of
radha these are great actors you know
what what are you apologizing for
so i do think it's um i think that they
the movement is capturing on something
which is true which is a sense that
there is a sense of guilt a colonial
guilt i think people do feel that sense
of colonial guilt and then it's been
targeted to undermine
good relationships and what's colonial
guilt well you know
there is a sense i think in people that
you know we just went all over the world
and took over and you know did some bad
things but and i think people think that
we
you know i go
we also gave people the rule of law
equality under law english language and
some really great infrastructure as well
so basically there does need to be a
balanced conversation but there's a lot
amongst certainly amongst um upper
middle class tends to be upper middle
class
well-educated uh white-skinned people
who really love their white guilt
colonialism thing do you know what i
mean yeah it gives them a
it gives them a hand in the game of the
woke poker
but it seems like with this film that
that we might be at the beginning of
the fight back against hollywood your
co-star gina carrano who was a star of
uh the lucas films mandalorian
mandalorian uh series uh
and she was cancelled from those uh that
series she for people who don't know she
was an mma fighter star the the sort of
most famous female mma fighter uh turned
uh movie star and uh she
now she got cancelled it was it was
because she put some social media out
comparing the treatment of republicans
to the treatment of the jews by the
nazis which
my personal taste is maybe
a bit far however
given that we're constantly
hearing how everyone's a nazi all the
time it seems a little bit hypocritical
that some as soon as someone who's got
republican uh sympathies uses the the
the nazi um reference gets loses her um
acting career uh it seems a little bit
unjust nevertheless gina is back with
you and uh not only that she's uh
with the daily why i've been making
other films
is this the beginning of of people
saying well we've had enough within your
industry we've had enough of hollywood
uh and the ideology the ideology the
ideological capture we're going to make
our own films you'd hope so wouldn't you
you but you know in an ideal world
hollywood would make some of them too it
has maverick top gun is not a um is not
an ideologically um synonymous with the
mainstream hollywood thinking so there
are and they do really well and the
terminal list as well the amazon thing
is also not um ideologically aligned
with hollywood so i think i think
they're starting to get a smell of it
but um
yeah i think it's probably going to have
to be about two parallel cultures for a
while which is a real shame because they
won't speak to each other which you want
them to
and um
it'll be interesting to see what happens
with this film i think i thought i spoke
to director and i think the website went
down because they have so many people
tried to download it so that was good on
day one
um and then
it's
director robert davie robert darwin yeah
and he you know we'll we'll just have to
see what i can say is i had to make it
was one of the nicest atmospheres i've
ever worked in
and gina
yeah you can say that this the hitlerian
thing is the minute someone starts going
down the hitlerian analogy path you've
already lost the argument there is that
to be said
but there is a rising authoritarianism
and it you know i don't really know what
else to compare joe biden's speech to
other than something you know you could
call it star warsian i suppose or but
it's joe biden's speech did you not see
his speech in pennsylvania was it oh i
saw a photograph it's really really
frightening so i think that her
analogies anyway i think she comes from
a spiritual place i spoke to her on that
i had a very very long chat with her the
other day because she turned off she's
removed her social media accounts
um not instagram but she's removed um
twitter and she just said i don't want
to give people access to me anymore and
i need to i want to rediscover art and
what it is and i think it's really
amazing that she's done that she's one
of the most
generous spirited
wonderfully clever
kind people
that i've ever worked with
and yet she's cast as this sort of evil
nazi you know that's what they say don't
they but they say that about me too
do you get a sense working with her of
of the climate in american political
culture where it seems from the outside
to be worse even in here yeah britain
she says it's a real match
and she um
she i should you know i've got to be
careful what i said i don't want to
speak for her obviously but yeah you
know if you think about it america
has a huge
one of the things that was pointed out
to me the other day which is really
interesting america almost everyone in
america is on a pill of some kind or
another for example you know and there's
obviously a huge opioid problem in
america and all of those drugs
are made in china
so if the china decides to turn off the
tap and the supply chain goes and you
suddenly have a bunch of americans that
all go into withdrawal at the same time
that could be quite a substantial
problem do you know what i mean i don't
know why i rambled off on that so
are you how are you linking that to
the conversation well i don't know but i
was thinking i didn't know it just it
was one of those things that shocked me
when i was told it i don't know how it
links sorry bad segway
forgive me um well uh but you you i have
now
really lent into a political career and
it's it's
really impressive that
with all the
all the abuse you you've got you've kind
of turned it around and you ran uh in
the london mayoral election and one yeah
and one of them
um uh
and now i understand you are uh you've
launched the bad law project what can
you tell us about that yeah because i
don't want to be a politician really i i
in fact i don't do a good job of fooling
everyone well
i'm cultural i care about the culture i
really do and i care about free speech
ultimately that's what i care about the
most
so um
the
bad law project is actually exists
to remove the politics from foundational
institutions like the police and the nhs
and
education and the church is possible but
look looks way too far gone um so it's
just to take the politics out of it
which is odd because the reclaimed party
exists to put some politics into things
so one would hope by removing the
politics from
[Music]
it's a political stance to try and
remove you know political how are you
doing that what's an example of that
well okay so darren brady the um
ex-military veteran who was given a
non-crime hate incident for sharing my
uh
post of the four pride flags together to
form the swastika
um which did you get suspended from
twitter for that i was suspended from
twitter for that as well yeah and then
and what did you have to remove the i
had to remove the offending tweet and
which i'm more than happy to do because
i did it just to prove exactly what was
going to happen would happen which is
what would an authoritarian totalitarian
do if you put up the wrong flag
they'd
make you remove it so i did that and
then he um he and you know one mustn't
quit there's only one flag that must not
be criticized which is interesting so
darren then reposted it and he didn't
even repost it he just said what do we
think of this
on facebook and he got
visited by two coppers and then
they rearranged to visit he contacted us
murder project and we made sure we were
there and we then
read them
the riot act and informed them of the
law that they were actually in
contravention of the law and not um
carrying out police procedure correctly
and stuff like that and we made a huge
ruckus and since then the chief
constable of hampshire police has been
removed and
that she's gone so that's one bad apple
out of the barrel which is a really good
thing
in terms of education we've got within
uh these this personal self so personal
social health and economic classes
sounds all very chilled and religious
and spiritual no it's not it's rsc
whatever that stands for and you're
having kids taught a gender ideology and
the concept of white privilege and
diversity and inclusion stuff like that
and that's very dangerous stuff to teach
kids so we will be taking out cases
against schools who adopt this man these
teaching practices in their pshg
classes and we have a we have a case
against a um prominent
clinic who are stopping a psychologist
getting promoted uh getting qualified
sorry because she will not admit her own
racism inherent racism
so that's
on that last example how that would be
um
an intrusion on someone specific and and
uh but with the school the school
example how would you how do you legally
fight the schools
uh teaching
gender ideology or crt how how do how do
you go about suing a school or well i
don't think it's so much about seeing
necessarily suing the school what it is
about drawing attend parents attention
to what the kids are being taught so the
parents
form
and come together to form groups to stop
it so you don't necessarily have to get
legal with it you just have to say
within this you know within the
for example
the legal route the legislative god i
hate saying words like that
root down would be to say that the pshe
does it which has no defined curriculum
you just the teachers just google it and
go i've got a huge psja watch and i
teach and promoted sources up the top of
things like stonewall young champions or
twinkle and other organizations that
promote all this stuff a legislative way
of doing it would to be give it give it
a defined curriculum
and decide what was and wasn't going to
go in there you know what critical race
theory being taught to children why
would you teach kids to be racist that's
a really bad idea so you can do it
legally but you can also do it just by
the just by the
thing of going to parents here's what's
being taught you know because parents
don't want to believe it they don't want
they you know they want to trust that
schools in local apprentice
are doing the best things to children
that they can but actually you know
schools are very very heavily involved
in the indoctrination of our kids you
know yeah and
it needs highlighting yeah have you
you've seen this in your own kid's
schools i imagine um only in one of them
the other school i'm actually pretty
impressed with um but yes that well
it's bad in in all schools you know um
yes but in one i asked for the teaching
resources and was just pretty blown away
what i can't understand is how on one
part of the
thing they teach about um
keeping signs
for fgm
watching out for the signs of fgm either
having taken place or about to take
place when girls reach puberty uh that
they may go for a slightly longer
holiday
back to their country of origin
to visit family you know for some sort
of you know and so we're teaching
keep an eye out
for the mutilation of young
innocent girls uh genitals but on the
other side you're saying
we're gonna teach that boys can be girls
and girls can be boys and promote the
idea of mutilating
children's genitals for a different
ideological reason so it's very
inconsistent and extremely dangerous
you know kids don't need that in their
heads kids it's the last thing a child
needs is to be taught
kids
being a child as you you know as we all
can remember is hard enough you know
discovering the world without being told
that there is no factual and there is no
permanent reality and that it's so
flexible that you could be a girl or a
boy it's just not true
so i think that's really dangerous in
schools it's certainly dangerous but it
feels like there's a little bit of a
turnaround now in the uk with the tavik
stock center being told it has to close
its doors there's the the the pushback
now is is gaining speed but i guess the
concept of truth of among
i mean the mutilation of children is
absolutely disgusting but very core the
idea that you're you're confusing
children about what truth is
sets you up for
you know very confusing adolescence talk
of everything yeah but it's the point of
it's the point of post-modernism isn't
it is to say that there's no such thing
as truth
but you know look where post-modernism
and marxism and that sort of thinking's
taken the world yeah you know it's
pretty it's a pretty dark and dangerous
area
so you're clearly a man
whose blood boils about some serious you
know very serious issues in society you
clearly
love your family and your your country
but is there is what's the driving force
what what are you so
okay what do you care most about what do
you what is it that that gets you
to do all of these many things that
you're everybody's right to an opinion
everyone has the right to one you know
and i don't like injustice naturally
because my mum was very strong on that
but she would always my mum was very
very much you know let people speak
listen to them draw them out find out
what they think you know disagree have
big rounds it's fine
but
listen and respect other people's point
of view or don't respect it but take it
seriously
don't just because um you know the
reason i think why a lot of conservative
thinking is shut down
is because it's very good at spotting
the inconsistencies of
you know extreme left thinking
so they just go right we've got to
cancel you because
you know we we cannot tolerate the
strength of your argument in return
whereas what you really want is you want
um
the more left-leaning ideas to
pick the inconsistencies of the more
right-leaning ideas and and have a sense
of things it's a free expression thing
for me and how can i walk onto a film
set
and act
if i've got or i'm already worried about
what i think
and whether i can express that how can
you create anything hence why a lot of
what we watch nowadays is pretty like
you know it's a bit kind of yawny a lot
of it so i think people the more people
become frightened to express themselves
the lower quality of drama you get the
lower quality of music you get the lower
quality of everything we want the most
quality and i just i also love talking
with people and listening to people
but um your
your
your consistency in in defending free
speech i think it was proved in your
defense of uh the football player trevor
sinclair who uh when
um her majesty the queen passed away
uh
i i guess attacked her in a tweet or
wouldn't be mourning grieving her i
don't remember exactly what he said
and is it talk sport or skype yeah i saw
it on talksport said um you know we've
been trying to contact don't worry
everyone we've been trying to contact
trevor sinclair to tell him we've been
distancing themselves from his views and
all that and it's like
guys no one's out to get you yeah you
know
if you just calm down for a minute for a
minute
he's totally entitled to say what he
thinks i think what he says is horrible
yeah
but
but it's one of the problems of free
speech you know you you some of it's
pretty horrible
and
so they suggest though that you know
earlier in this conversation that you've
you've
hinted that it's it's a problem of of
the woke let's say or progressive
capture of certain institutions but the
free speech issue is certainly not just
a left-wing or
progressive uh
problem there's people
trevor sinclair in this sense would be
the the progressive who's
he's the right wing
to cancel exactly yeah and that's bad
you know and it's why why be the
opposite of them
that's not what you want in life you
know we're all
without going becoming too spiritual
about it we're all unique and we're all
equal as well
so
you shouldn't pitch your tent above
somebody else so you have to be
consistent and unfortunately that does
come with going
yeah trev i think that's a pretty
nasty thing to say but you have a right
to say it and people have a right to go
cancel him but i'm just not going to be
one of them i don't believe in
cancelling people i don't really i don't
believe in um
i think the suppression of i think
everything revolves around free speech
without it we have succumbed
unless we hold on to it we are
we're over there you know as
democracy is over the west is over
the west is built around the ideas of
free speech you know other other
cultures are not built around the idea
of free speech they're built around the
ideas of compelled speech and look at
the directions they go in you don't find
people
on dinghies from australia to china
you know you do find them on
walking across the rio grande from
mexico into
um the usa you know people head towards
places where free speeches
sacrosanct they don't head in the other
direction
uh well um lawrence thank you so much
for your time today and can you tell
listeners how they can watch your new
film
my son hunter i think i think you can go
to uh
www.mysonhunter.com
i think
uh
and yeah it's uh
or you can yeah and then you
tap on it i haven't done it i'm told
it's easy i'm not going to pay for a
film i was in i'll get a free screening
actually can you send me the screen that
they sent you i got a screen yeah um i
haven't seen it yet so um and then you
click on it and it sends you a six digit
text message code and then you're up
well uh i've seen the film and it's if
you don't understand the hunter biden
story it's a great entry point to get
into what is a very
murky
confusing keep in mind the laptop there
were tens of thousands of emails not all
of which have been verified but a good
amount have been verified so it's a very
kind of nebulous uh world to enter but
the the the the ex ex
certainly this film goes into exposing
the president's links to uh uh this this
corruption within ukraine in china and
uh beyond and i um
i recommend it to listeners i'm sure
you'll enjoy and lawrence
congratulations for being back behind a
camera
and on the silver screen thanks my love
[Music]
you